c'est qui ton joueur préféré taux de
pont paul pogba est battu c'est quoi
j'ai une énorme surprise pour toi
paul pogba il t'a laissé un petit
message regarde coucou depuis manchester
je sais que tu es fan de moi cyril
surprise le patron
le patron jean pierre foucault est-ce
qu'on lève ce mec
mais si elle pas trop qu'est-ce qui est
trop la tête et mme paul moreau
jean-pierre au thème était content pour
paul pogba quoi c'était la surprise que
sous les terres voilà tu es contente a
surpris de mon chéri allez merci d'avoir
été là mr simon ciric
merci merci merci messieurs allez merci
merci d'abord exclamé manuel burga
revient à bâle et le chien est revenue
croyez vraiment que je vous ai fait
venir pour sa chérie tu fais aujourd'hui
est ce que tu veux venir avec moi à
l'aéroport on part à manchester il ya un
max ce soir manchester united contre bof
moi ya paul pogba qui joue on pourra pas
le voir mais on va voir le match ça ne
chauffe ou pas oui malheureusement j'ai
pas les billets montmédy tu pars à
manchester imiter
oui
[Musique]
c'est la gauche qui parle pas
merci seco
[Musique]
ak
texte
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on a kiffé way pour 1 0 bon tu m'as tu
content quoi passer une bonne journée
une tribune j'ai mangé toi oui enfin qui
singe il faut faire quoi tu parles on va
faire quoi tu vas dans son âge
la première fois que tu vas manchester
ouais ça prend un poids tumour match
eric avec moi tu stein et il en vrai
c'est quasiment du tout en fait
j'ai pas fait libre
c'était pour que
les déposants
je crois juste un truc après ce mardi
ça
bonjour alors la santé mehdi c'est
merveilleux comment tu vas bien on est
content parce qu'on peut te l'a laissé
pendant trois quatre jours est ce qu'il
a fait pour toi tu as lu dans la loge et
où tu vas dans n'importe quel pays tu
feras ce club merci au progrès
[Musique]
c
[Applaudissements]
à ce rythme là sur dix pourrait quitter
l'hôpital
je tente encore réagi merci merci
beaucoup merci beaucoup
franchement tu es tu là non franchement
j'ai dit la vérité ça marque vraiment
vraiment vraiment plaisir il n'en dit
pas plus à tes deux heures je l'entends
plus main et l'arrêté parle jamais dans
mes bras sont arrivés non pas par des
bisous la note est pas de besoin on joue
on n'a pas qui fait aussi des
combinaisons remercier cyril d'avoir
organisé cette journée debout mais aussi
paul pogba lorsque nous avons reçu chez
lui
tout ce que tu as fait pour lui la
journée qu'on a passé à sa merci
infiniment merci zizou
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
à
un aquifère et pour le poc bas c'est un
mec vraiment exceptionnel ce tempo est
bon mon frérot vraiment bravo paul
[Musique]